pese al rechazo de la comunidad
internacional cuatro regiones del este y
del sur de Ucrania controladas por
autoridades prorusas llevaron a cabo
unos referendos digamos unos referendos
de autodeterminación si se le puede
llamar así que según su reportes
aprobaron por una altísima votación su
incorporación a la federación de Rusia
veamos el mapa para ponernos en contexto
estamos hablando de las regiones de
Daniel's Club saporiya y gerson la
franja que ustedes ven en color gris son
territorios que pertenecen a doñez y
alugansk pero que todavía están bajo
control ucraniano vemos también en un
color un poco un rojo un poco más fuerte
la Península de crimea que ya fue
anexada a Rusia tras un controvertido
referendo en el año 2014 un referendo
muy parecido a lo que estamos viendo en
este momento
recientemente las autoridades de estas
cuatro regiones anunciaron que preveen
solicitar muy pronto al presidente de
Rusia Vladimir Putin la incorporación
oficial a la federación de Rusia vamos a
darles más contexto con los siguientes
datos de llegar a concretarse Entonces
esta incorporación en el caso de doniesk
y Lucas solamente entrarían los
territorios que comprenden las
autodenominadas repúblicas populares de
doñez y lugans que tampoco cuentan con
reconocimiento internacional como
tampoco cuentan con reconocimiento las
medidas que toman sus gobiernos
autoproclamados en este caso realizar
este tipo de referendos como ya les
decía hay una franja de territorio que
todavía está bajo control ucraniano hay
que decir que la mayoría de la población
sobre todo Indonesia y lugans son
rusoparlantes étnicamente son eslavos
pero muchos de Ellos no hablan ucraniano
con fluidez y han crecido compartiendo
digamos una mezcla de culturas tanto
rusa como ucraniana estas cuatro
regiones representan una buena parte del
motor económico de Ucrania son zonas
ampliamente industrializadas donde hay
industria minera hay industria
aeronáutica hay centros académicos hay
puertos solamente por nombrar algunos
datos justamente Si de algo se va a
beneficiar Rusia con esta posible
incorporación es por tener control total
de las costas del mar de los puertos que
hay sobre estas costas también le
permitirá a Rusia tener un corredor
terrestre que comunica a la federación
con la Península de crimea dando una
opción adicional al paso que existe a
través del estrecho de kers
Ucrania y prácticamente toda la
comunidad internacional ha negado la
legitimidad de estas consultas la ONU
también la otan dijeron que no van a
reconocer los resultados sucederá
Entonces lo mismo que sucedió hace
algunos años con crimea que ante la
mirada del mundo Ucrania perdió esta
histórica región y nadie hizo nada para
impedirlo la actual guerra Entonces cómo
se va a ver afectada con esta
incorporación de estos territorios será
un nuevo punto de giro para este
conflicto que busca Rusia con esta
incorporación que va a ser la comunidad
internacional y sobre todo qué va a
hacer Ucrania ante esta posible ruptura
de su integridad territorial lo vamos a
analizar aquí en el debate de France 24
para conversar sobre este tema hemos
invitado a la doctora beata boina ella
es internacionalista también es
profesora de relaciones internacionales
del tec de Monterrey sede Ciudad de
México ella fue embajadora de Polonia en
México y Centroamérica entre los años
2014 y 2018 y también está con nosotros
Andrés servín él Es doctor en ciencias
políticas también es analista
internacional es presidente del Tin Tank
regional Cris y se encuentra en la
ciudad de Marbella en el sur de España
ustedes nuestros televidentes también
hacen parte de esta conversación ustedes
ya lo saben pueden dejar preguntas
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales estamos en Twitter en Instagram
y en Facebook nos encuentra como arroba
france24_es@santilogo que es mi cuenta
personal la etiqueta para que dejen los
comentarios numeral el debate f24 ya lo
saben también pueden ver nuestra señal
en vivo nuestro streaming a través de
YouTube y también nuestros contenidos
están disponibles en nuestro podcast el
programa todos los programas de El
Debate los puede encontrar en Apple
podcast Spotify deezer y tuning
comienzo entonces dándole la palabra a
la doctora beata boina en la ciudad de
México para conocer nuestro Punto de
partida Como me gusta Llamar a la
primera pregunta para conocer opiniones
de los invitados doctora bobina Gracias
por estar con nosotros y Punto de
partida son o no legítimos estos
referendos que se han celebrado en estas
cuatro regiones del este y del sur de
Ucrania Cuál es su opinión
buenas tardes buenas noches Muchas
gracias por la invitación Pues la verdad
es que son totalmente ilegítimos de esos
referéndums porque es parte del
territorio de Ucrania es una parte
ocupada por las fuerzas armadas rusas
pero no cabe duda que este si alguien
tuviera la autoridad para
permitir la celebración de esos
referéndulos Pues sería el gobierno en
este contexto de Ucrania y esos
referéndum se celebran en este contexto
de la ocupación rusa de la parte
oriental y parte sur de Ucrania Pero por
otra parte también se celebran en un
contexto de la guerra entonces las
capacidades realmente de Rusia en ese en
ese contexto de garantizar las
circunstancias adecuadas para la
celebración de referéndums Tampoco
tampoco son los las adecuadas de hecho
pues hemos visto en algunas algunos
fragmentos que nos han llegado digamos
de esos referéndums que los los
funcionarios supuestamente encargados de
organizar esos referendos pues estaban
acompañados incluso de los personas con
armas no lo cual refleja básicamente
que se vive en ese contexto ahora Saluda
al doctor Andrés cervin en la ciudad de
Marbella en España doctor servin Gracias
por estar con nosotros Punto de partida
son legítimos o no Estos son referendos
está usted de acuerdo con lo que ha
dicho la doctora boina Cuál es su punto
de vista
mi punto de vista es que depende de que
desde donde se mire son legítimos o son
muy legítimos El problema es que estos
son referendas que deberían haberse
llevado a cabo mucho antes en el marco
de los acuerdos de minss que en 2015 que
ya no respetó y que de alguna manera
fueron un factor también en la
operación especial así llamada por parte
de Rusia creo que es un referendo una
serie de referencias tardíos este en su
momento si se hubieran hecho con
gonnettes y Lucas por lo menos en
términos de
las características Cómo se podrían
insertar en un nuevo sistema político
ucraniano que era parte de los acuerdos
de Minsk si hubieran tenido obviamente
muchísima más legitimidad en este
momento la comunidad occidental si
rechaza la legitimidad Pero hay otros
actores del sistema internacional que
todavía no se han expresado al respecto
y desde luego Rusia tiene una posición
muy clara acerca de la incorporación de
este territorio doctor servin continuó
con usted Quiero preguntarle para
entender el contexto de lo que está
sucediendo Cuál es Entonces el argumento
que da la federación de Rusia Para
apoyar este tipo de consultas que son
organizadas por estos autoproclamados
gobiernos de la repúblicas populares por
lo menos en doñez y lugans pero en el
caso de saporijson son gobiernos que han
llegado han tomado el poder digámoslo
así a raíz de la invasión y de la
presencia de las tropas rusas Cuáles son
Entonces los argumentos de estos cuatro
territorios para realizar estas
consultas y el apoyo que da Rusia
bueno los argumentos de fondo
básicamente tienen que ver con el
carácter ruso para parlante y vinculado
a la sociedad de rusa de estos
territorios
Esos son los argumentos de carácter
cultural ahí Ahora hay argumentos de
carácter mucho más drástico si ustedes
quieren hay una ocupación de desarrollo
y jerson por parte de las tropas rusas y
esto ha ampliado
el espacio de potencial anexión a
incorporación de estos territorios a la
federación rusa en función del interés
ruso de
diluir disminuir la amenaza de una
confrontación con eventualmente con la
otan utilizando como base el territorio
de ucraniano
doctora boina Cuál es su opinión los
argumentos que puede tener Moscú y estas
cuatro regiones para terminar de armar
este rompecabezas Mira yo creo que hay
que hay que este esclarecer muy bien El
Punto de partida los referéndums 4 los
referentes que se acaban de celebrar en
cuatro regiones de Ucrania no son
referéndums de Independencia los pueblos
que viven ahí no se no se les preguntó
si quieren ser independientes sino que
se les preguntó si quieren anexarse a la
federación rusa y en ese sentido Yo creo
que si de alguna forma podemos
justificar en varios contextos digamos
regionales los referéndums de
independencia este como fue el caso de
kosovo por ejemplo cuando
y la declaración de independencia de
kosovo Pues la verdad es que justificar
un referéndum sobre la anexión
organizado bajo básicamente digamos
fuerza de la federación rusa y en un
territorio ocupado pues este es bueno un
poco yo diría es una argumentación
bastante bastante débil obviamente para
qué le sirve a Rusia organizar esos
referéndulos de anexión para tener una
justificación interna que realmente pues
se ha llevado a cabo un proceso de
consultas a través precisamente de esa
de esa consulta entre comillas popular
que le permite a Rusia o a Putin
básicamente a ponerse en frente de la
duma rusa del parlamento ruso Pues a
finales de esta semana La semana que
viene y declarar que vamos a cumplir con
el deseo de los pueblos de Ucrania del
este Ucrania del sur los vamos a
incorporar a la federación rusa y es
este Incluso en los regímenes
autoritarios como lo es la federación
rusa pues se necesita de alguna forma la
justificación para las decisiones que se
están tomando Y esa es la el argumento
principal que podemos ver aquí porque
Rusia ha decidido hacer esos referéndums
y hay perfecto yo creo que muy relevante
en el momento que Rusia decide
incorporar anexar esos territorios a la
federación rusa los va a tratar
obviamente como parte de la federación
rusa y va a aplicar a esos territorios
pues la doctrina de seguridad la
doctrina de defensa que existe en toda
la federación rusa y puede usar
precisamente ese argumento de que ya son
los territorios de la federación rusa
para pues desarrollar una nueva
estrategia en esta guerra de Rusia
contra Ucrania y ese punto que estamos
viendo hoy en esos momentos justamente
en la guerra de Rusia contra Ucrania los
referéndums posible anexión en breve
Pues sí cambia sustancialmente el
panorama de esta de esta guerra y la
puede llevar incluso a una escalada muy
peligrosa esa es una de las preguntas
que tengo para para debatir aquí en el
programa doctora boina antes de llegar
allá Quiero preguntarle por lo que está
viendo Europa y lo que está viendo el
mundo entero que está sucediendo en el
este de Europa pero Tal parece que no se
está haciendo mucho o no hay una
reacción Más allá de rechazar
simplemente la realización de los
referendos Tal parece que Europa está
más concentrado en las fugas del Norte
Stream y en el problema energético que
en darle importancia a estos territorios
que posiblemente pueden llegar a ser
anexados a la federación en cuestión de
días o semanas el mundo entero va a
dejar que pase otra vez como lo que pasó
con crimea que se salió de las manos del
control ucraniano y nadie hizo nada
Mira yo creo que el occidente está
haciendo bastante Para apoyar a Ucrania
en su guerra contra contra Rusia a
través de este envío de armamento ayuda
militar ayuda económica ayuda
humanitaria ahora bien occidente también
me da la sensación que ha sido muy
cauteloso para no anticiparse en sus
reacciones y no llevar a una escalada
digamos muy peligrosa en esta en esta
guerra porque pues en juego está Incluso
el uso de las armas nucleares digamos
tomando en consideración las
declaraciones que ha hecho el presidente
Putin Entonces en ese sentido yo creo
que la reacción del accidente es como la
hemos visto a lo largo de esos últimos
meses no anticiparse digamos a lo que va
a ocurrir Aunque Sí este estoy segura
que están ahí evaluando en los en los
gabinetes de los primeros ministros
ministerios de defensa pues diferentes
escenarios frente a lo que está pasando
hoy en día en el contexto de Rusia no
pero no anticiparse para no generar una
escalada in Yo creo que es relevante en
este escenario también lo que pasa es
que con estos referendos doctora boina
ya le doy la palabra al doctor servín es
que no anticiparse y ser preventivo
significaría perder estas regiones
dejarlas incorporar en Rusia y tal vez
habría que reaccionar y no prevenir como
lo vio usted doctor servín la comunidad
internacional se queda quieta inmóvil en
el marco de la ley no hay nada que pueda
castigar a Rusia por por apoyar estos
referendos
bueno es obvio que las Naciones Unidas
no han podido poner en marcha ningún
mecanismo ni siquiera para impulsar
algún tipo de salida negociado o
pacífica a la situación esto por un lado
el caso de la comunidad europea está muy
claro que hay un conflicto entre lo que
la comunidad europea alargó la como
valores y lo que son los intereses
concretos de sus respectivos miembros
particularmente los referente a la
previsión energética y a los efectos que
esto está causando en muchas de las
sociedades europeas en donde hay
bastante contento por lo que va a
suceder este invierno en términos del
incremento de los precios de energía de
los alimentos de hecho la inflación
misma que se está produciendo en muchos
de estos países europeos Entonces esta
contradicción No termina de resolverse
desde luego ahora también entra un nuevo
factor con las elecciones de los
resultados de las elecciones en Italia
donde hay posiciones encontradas con
respecto a cómo seguir con las sanciones
con respecto a Rusia Entonces estamos en
un
conferente un panorama bastante complejo
por parte de la Unión Europea Hasta qué
punto va a poder sostener algún tipo de
posición o escalar inclusive en términos
de las sanciones que pueden poner a
Rusia que yo lo veo
bastante difícil de inmediato doctor
servín sigo con usted y Quiero
preguntarle ahora por lo que
significaría para el conflicto para la
instancia en la que está el conflicto en
Ucrania este rompimiento de la unidad
territorial ucraniana perder estas
regiones del este como ya lo explicaba
yo en la introducción son parte del
motor económico de Ucrania que valga
decir es un país que está atravesando
una profunda crisis económica pero es
donde está su zona más industrializada
bueno en este momento Estamos de acuerdo
con que esa es la zona más
industrializada la zona más rica que
Rusia se asegura de esta manera a través
del referéndum como parte eventualmente
de la misma federación rusa Y eso va a
afectar a la economía de Ucrania pero
también tenemos por otro lado que en la
inyección financiera muy importante no
solamente armamentística sino financiera
muy importante de ayuda Europea y
estadounidense y canadiense y de Gran
Bretaña
a Ucrania y esto relativamente balancea
a corto plazo lo que puede estar
sucediendo en términos de la economía
ucraniana
a mediano plazo y largo plazo si esos
territorios se incorporan a la
federación rusa y evidentemente va a
tener un impacto negativo sobre la
economía ucraniana y aquí desde luego
está este insistente llamado de el
presidente Celeste No solamente la ayuda
militar por parte de occidente a Ucrania
sino también a una ayuda más sustancial
en términos de aporte financieros Pero
esto es otro tema que se complejiza por
las naciones y por lo que está pasando
en el mundo en el ámbito de la
polarización de espacios de gobernanza
financiera global diferenciadas entre
eurasia y occidente pero nosotros los
demás que no voy a entrar a tratar ahora
me imagino que nosotros programa y
doctora boina su opinión sobre este
sobre esta desarticulación de Ucrania
sería
un Punto de partida para una escalada en
este conflicto que Rusia responde
militarmente Ucrania también tratando de
preservar su integridad también responda
militarmente y estemos ante una nueva
escalada de combates allí en el este
era yo creo que sí podemos estar ante
una nueva escalada del combate eso no
cabe ninguna duda Por otra parte es
relevante apuntar aquí que esta
este desmembramiento de Ucrania como lo
están mencionando es así como lo quiere
presentar también Rusia no O sea Rusia
seguirá luchando por la integridad
territorial yo creo que en cuanto a eso
no hay ninguna duda y los ucranias
seguirán luchando por la integridad
territorial en cuanto a eso no hay duda
y lo han demostrado los ucranianos
durante esos casi siete meses de la
guerra y hay un tercer punto la parte de
Ucrania Oriental es una parte importante
desde el punto de vista económico desde
el punto de vista Industrial pero
también recordemos que desde 2014
efectivamente el Gobierno ucraniano no
tiene control sobre lugares idóneas y de
esos territorios la verdad es que ha
habido una gran parte de la población
sea deteriorado también la capacidad de
desarrollo económico en esta región y la
capacidad del funcionamiento de las
empresas muchas de las cuales han salido
precisamente de drogas y dones Entonces
en ese sentido Ucrania durante esos años
que han pasado 2014 ha aprendido de
alguna forma a vivir sin esas dos
regiones Rurales idóneas la situación se
complica Obviamente con la situación en
en saporosis y en gerson porque son esas
regiones que le daban acceso también a
Ucrania al mar asof y total el acceso a
Ucrania a los a los mares básicamente es
uno de los objetivos de Rusia en esta en
esta guerra para debilitar a este a este
país y y Si vemos que qué puede ocurrir
digamos en el futuro una escalada sin
ninguna duda porque Ucrania seguirá
intentando recuperar sus territorios y
Rusia está dispuesta a seguir
manteniendo su presencia militar en esos
territorios lo cual no se refleja
básicamente en esa llamada a la
movilización de los reclutas de 300.000
reclutas incluso quizás se está hablando
de cifras cifras mayores Entonces vamos
a estar probablemente Durante los
próximos meses en una especie de
confrontación muy si para lo que vimos
digamos
en Esas últimas semanas para que Rusia
pueda mantener sus líneas de digamos de
combate su Ucrania avanzar en lo que en
lo que vemos en el frente de esta de
esta guerra ahora bien Hasta qué punto
utiliza esta dispuesto a usar un abanico
más amplio del armamento pues queda ver
no incluyendo aquí el tema del armamento
nuclear y la amenaza más bien de uso de
armas nucleares que ese es el gran temor
que tiene la comunidad internacional sé
que ustedes dos no son estrategas
militares y es muy difícil entender a
este punto Pese a que llevamos más de
seis meses en este conflicto entender
cuál es la estrategia que tiene el
presidente de Rusia en su cabeza a nivel
militar pero vimos un escenario 2014
pierden crimea 2022 estas cuatro
regiones pueden anexarse es un conflicto
que desde el 2014 viene como con un
largo aliento y Tal parece que se va a
prolongar estamos doctor servinante de
un conflicto que se va a extender por
muchos más años y que poco a poco va a
ir desarticulando a Ucrania paso a paso
digamos que después de este escenario
las fuerzas rusas intentan tomar el
resto de las costas ucranianas
suponiendo las costas de odesa para
poder llegar hasta la región de
transnistria puede ser un paso a seguir
por las tropas rusas como lo ve bueno
primero yo creo que va a seguir el juego
de ofensivas en contra ofensivas entre
ambas partes frente a la contraofensiva
que recién desarrolló Ucrania Rusia se
está preparando para una no solamente
asegurar los territorios sino
probablemente para una nueva ofensiva
pues es altamente probable que si hay
una ofensiva esta se dirija a ocupar el
puerto de Odessa y llegar hasta
trasmestre como para garantizar que
Rusia controla todo tipo de salida de
Ucrania hacia el mar no solo a Job sino
también el mar Negro eso es una
posibilidad no habría que verlo como con
los estrategas militares como lo ven
pero en mi opinión lo que pasa es que en
ninguno de los dos partes está dispuesta
a dar el brazo a torcer ni a iniciar
algún tipo de negociaciones que puedan
llevar algún tipo de acuerdo de paz Más
que nada porque las dos se sienten
agraviadas por razones distintas pero
que giran en torno fundamentalmente al
incumplimiento como dije al principio de
los acuerdos de Minsk y a la expansión
de la otan por el parte de Rusia que
siente que se convierte en una amenaza y
en esto entran a tallar también muchos
elementos en juego y se dan en la
comunidad internacional y yo quiero
recordar porque a veces se se ve de una
manera un poco distorsionada que la
semana pasada Tuvimos una cumbre de la
Organización de cooperación de Shanghai
en donde la prensa occidental insistió
muchísimo sobre los Reproches que
pudiera haberle hecho el Primer Ministro
modi y a Putin o el presidente pero en
realidad lo más importante es que de la
Cumbre sale un acuerdo de profundizar la
conectividad la infraestructura y las
relaciones económicas en el marco de
eurasia incluyendo la generación de un
espacio de dolarizado Y esto es un punto
muy importante porque marca una
diferenciación con lo que es el mundo
occidental y lo que es el mundo Más que
nada en el marco del funcionamiento del
dólar del ámbito del dólar por parte de
su manejo por Estados Unidos doctor
cervin continuó con usted justamente ya
que usted habla del tema internacional A
qué se está exponiendo el presidente
Putin con esta incorporación de estos
territorios más sanciones más
aislamiento esto como puede afectar a
Rusia
yo creo que estoy viendo que la
comunidad europea en particular la Unión
Europea está como muy indecisa en seguir
avanzando en más sanciones porque teme
que las consecuencias sean del mismo
efecto del mismo efecto Boomerang que
han tenido hasta ahora no
en lo que se refiere a las economías de
occidente Entonces yo creo que ahí va a
haber todo una situación de impasse yo
diría hasta tanto se toma una decisión y
es muy difícil que haya un consenso
entre los 27 con respecto a Qué medidas
tomar por otro lado lo que estamos
viendo Es que se ha incrementado el
comercio entre los países de la
Organización de cooperación de Shanghai
y en el ámbito euroasiático y es no
solamente con China y la India que Rusia
comercia cada vez más y con los países
de Asia central Que obviamente estaban
dentro de su órbita durante la unión
soviética sino que también se expande a
la asociación de estados del sudeste a y
otros ámbitos en donde se acrecienta el
comercio No doctora boina su opinión son
las sanciones una manera de frenar esta
esta aspiración del presidente Putin
Cómo puede reaccionar la comunidad
internacional
Mira las acciones Es una herramienta muy
importante en ese contexto en el cual no
queremos usar la fuerza y no queremos
entrar en guerra pero sí dar a entender
a Putin de que este esa violación del
derecho internacional con la invasión
rusa Ucrania pues no puede tener lugar
en El Siglo 21 ha habido hasta ahora
seis paquetes de sanciones de la Unión
Europea que han abordado diferentes
ámbitos económicos financiero energético
también y la verdad es que se está
preparando El séptimo paquete los
resultados de estas acciones ya se están
viendo y hay diferentes indicios
indicadores de que Rusia no lo pasa bien
realmente la población rusa pero las
empresas rusas sobre todo tampoco
incluso la industria armamentística rusa
tampoco lo pasa también y por otra parte
a partir de diciembre de este año se va
a entrar en vigor una de las acciones yo
creo que más relevantes los europeos
dejan de comprar el petróleo a Rusia y
el petróleo es uno de los grandes
fuentes de ingresos de este país en
estos momentos está planeando también
poner el límite de precios al petróleo
este que se compra en general en el
mundo en la desde desde distintas partes
del mundo especialmente de Rusia en la
Unión Europea Entonces sí hay
herramientas y sanciones es una de estas
herramientas importantes que frente a
digamos la cautela de no entrar en
guerra de forma directa para no provocar
la transformación de la guerra entre dos
países en una guerra mundial Yo creo que
es una de las medidas de las pocas
medidas que se pueden aplicar obviamente
tienes son acciones es un arma de doble
filo afecta a Rusia sin duda también
afecta a los países europeos doctora
boina y que hay al interior de Rusia el
apoyo que tenga que tiene el presidente
Putin en esta altura del conflicto vemos
las imágenes de los ciudadanos rusos
abarrotando las fronteras terrestres
pagando cantidades de dinero para poder
abandonar el país en algún vuelo que los
lleve alguno de los países vecinos Qué
tanto está siendo apoyado el presidente
en esta instancia del conflicto después
de haber convocado a las reservas y de
este proceso de incorporación de estas
regiones
Mira es una decisión de Putin que es muy
costosa desde el punto de vista de su
imagen y desde el punto de vista
justamente del apoyo que con el cual ha
contado hasta ahora la como lo llaman en
Rusia operación especial en dónde vas la
movilización es un cambio de ecuación y
vemos justamente no solamente las
manifestaciones en diferentes ciudades
pero sobre todo cientos de miles de
personas que están intentando salir de
este de este país es Igualmente un arma
que permite sin ninguna duda o permitirá
hacer ninguna duda a Rusia mantener
operaciones militares en el este y sur
de Ucrania Pero por otra parte va a
estar afectando mucho a la población Y
eso se debe revertir en un plazo Yo
diría que corto mediano mediano plazo
sumándose precisamente también a los
resultados de las sanciones dentro de la
federación rusa doctor servin su opinión
sobre este tema el apoyo que tiene Putin
en el interior de la Federación
bueno Es evidente que ha habido una
serie de protestas y gente que ha sido
detenida a raíz de esas propuestas desde
luego en la reticencia que por parte de
algunos ciudadanos a
sumarse a la guerra porque nos han
reclutado pero no tenemos que olvidar
Cuáles son los factores en la élite que
deciden sobre esto Y pareciera que
dentro de la ley política rusa política
militar yo diría hay un fuerte sector
que apuesta a avanzar más en la guerra y
eso lo han expresado reiteradas veces no
solamente
digamos sectores dentro de los
hidrodictivos
de seguridad sino también dentro de la
duma encabezados por ejemplo por
el secretario general del partido
comunista que supuestamente está en la
oposición al partido de Putin pero sí se
ha expresado a favor de profundizar la
guerra entonces hay una hay una
contradicción ahí muy fuerte que hay que
tener en cuenta entre lo que es la
aspiración incluso medio el ruso da pie
que quizás evidentemente no quiere la
guerra no quiere seguir avanzando por
ese camino y hay sectores de la élite
que están muy claramente identificados
con un espíritu de mayor
énfasis patriotero de la necesidad de
avanzar en la guerra y eventualmente de
llegar a avanzar mucho más mismo en el
territorio ucraniano doctora boina estos
en referendos y de llevarse a cabo esta
incorporación de estas regiones a la
federación Rusia rusa podría generar un
nuevo Éxodo de ciudadanos ucranianos
hacia Europa está Europa países como por
ejemplo Polonia Hungría eslovenia
Rumanía Eslovaquia Perdón preparados
para recibir nuevamente llegadas de
ciudadanos ucranianos a raíz de estas
incorporaciones
Mira los países de la Unión Europea que
acabas de mencionar están preparados
obviamente para recibir
más refugiados de Ucrania ahora bien no
se prevén en esos momentos que haya más
refugiados porque todos los que tenían
pensado salir de esos territorios que
han realizado esos referéndums ya lo han
hecho con anterioridad y efectivamente
Pues ya hay una un gran grupo de
ucranianos de esos territorios y también
de parte de Ucrania central que en su
momento pues salieron de este país pero
en este momento dado que la federación
rusa ha realizado los referéndums y está
controlando los territorios dombas
lugares
ya desde hace algunos algunos meses Pues
la verdad es que los que tenían que
salir realmente han salido ya de estos
de estos territorios vamos llegando ya
al último bloque a la parte final del
programa y llegamos al momento de las
conclusiones de lo que puede suceder en
las próximas semanas y lo que puede
pasar allí en el este de Ucrania y en
este conflicto comienzo entonces con el
doctor servín para hacer las
conclusiones lo que sigue sanciones a
Rusia movimientos por parte de occidente
reclamos Cuál es el escenario que usted
ve para las próximas semanas
pero es que posiblemente haya un intento
de incrementar las sanciones
accidentales a Rusia por un lado por
otro lado va a incrementarse la
presencia militar rusa en términos
posiblemente de una ofensiva en Ucrania
Pero lo que más me preocupa a corto
mediano plazo es que no hay ningún
planteamiento de ambas partes ni de la
comunidad internacional Más allá del
llamado del secretario general de las
Naciones Unidas y de algunos mandatarios
algún mecanismo eficiente para empezar
una conversación que llegue algún tipo
de acuerdo o algún tipo de diálogo que
posibilita establecer alguna forma de
acuerdo específico entre las dos partes
eso creo que es lo más preocupante y eso
creo que es el gran fracaso de la
comunidad internacional en este momento
sí un gran fracaso así lo han calificado
varios analistas internacionales y hacen
capacidad que tiene Naciones Unidas de
concretar ideas Más allá del Consejo de
Seguridad se quedan en el debate y hay
poca acción doctora boina su conclusión
lo que vamos a ver en los próximos días
mira con los referéndums y la posible
anexión de esos territorios de la
federación rusa estamos entrando en una
nueva fase de la guerra una fase que se
caracteriza por este
una posibilidad posible
escalada también en ese sentido Rusia va
a intentar mantenerse en esos
territorios que ya tiene controlados
pero la verdad es que desconocemos
realmente Cuáles son las intenciones de
Putin en el sentido de uso de amenaza de
armas de armas nucleares y con ese tema
La verdad es que la comunidad
internacional el occidente yo creo que
está está muy pendiente para controlar
ese tema y no para no permitir que se
salga esa guerra digamos del control y
llegue al tema del uso de armamento
nuclear y por otra parte Finalmente nos
esperan varios meses más me da la
sensación Aunque hay algunos actores
internacionales que intentan participar
en las negociaciones o proponer
propuestas de negociación y aquí yo
rescataría al presidente de Turquía
erdogan que sigue siendo interlocutor
tanto por tanto para Putin como para el
presidente y ha logrado pues sentar en
alguna ocasión a la mesa de negociación
a las dos partes no a los presidentes
pero sí a las dos partes Yo creo que por
ahí eventualmente puede llegar en algún
momento una solución negociada cuando
las partes quieran sentarse a la mesa
doctora beata boina y doctora Andrés
servil Muchas gracias por haber estado
con nosotros haber hecho este análisis
para la audiencia de Francia 24 es todo
por hoy En nombre del equipo técnico Les
agradecemos su sintonía la producción
del programa estuvo a cargo de Pedro
Ruiz y la producción de invitados estuvo
a cargo de Tania Herrera Muchas gracias
Pueden seguir con la programación de
France 24